so just how did olympus fall because of
that guy of course how did the white
house fall the Koreans who else Olympus
has fallen so Olympus has fallen as
directed by Antoine Fuqua and it's
ultimately the siege of the White House
the movie that's right the North Koreans
have finally gotten pissed off - like
alright let's just get this over with
let's do this why the North Koreans cuz
it's 2013 80s had the Russians 90s had
the Russians after the year 2000 pick a
Middle Eastern country they were the bad
guys in the movies now we got the North
Koreans who will it be after 2020 who
knows but probably Australia I see you
guys hiding down there waiting so the
White House gets taken over everyone
gets massacred and wiped out except the
one man who used to be a Secret Service
agent but he's not a Secret Service
agent anymore but he's played by Gerard
Butler which means he is the last and
only hope to save the day or Olympus aka
the White House take over the White
House everyone's vulnerable the
Washington Monument like you know the
dick of America gets crumbled to the
ground America lost his house and its
direction all in one movie we got
Leonidas to save the day so that is not
nothing now everyone has rightfully
compared this movie to die hard I will
say it's simply like this it's like die
hard and 24 had a lovechild
it's like someone saw that whole White
House siege segment in 24 season seven
and they were like okay but what if we
took it the extra mile
yeah the extra mile is not Citizen Kane
by any means but the extra mile is
pretty frickin cool I had a good time
with this movie I mean is it believable
oh pretty cliche everyone takes over the
White House takes the president hostage
because they want the nuclear launch
codes but I still dug this movie Aaron
Eckhart's the president you know it's
like if Harvey Dent never got his face
blasted off and he was still a cool dude
he would probably end up being president
and so he would be president in this
movie best thing about we Americans we
like cool action movies but if you can
incorporate a really awesome president
within that yeah we're down with this
movie granted it's pretty much science
fiction at that point because who are we
kidding that shit's not happening but
that's why we like it I mean Gerard
Butler is a one-man army badass in that
he's like Jack Bauer ie this guy is Jack
Bauer
but he cracks a couple of one-liners and
you talk some [ __ ] and you're like okay
now you're John McClane just a really
likable dude who's a badass necessary in
most action movies but this movie did it
right
I thought this movie was going to be
like great be action movie with bad CGI
and you can always tell when there's a
green screen certainly tell when the CGI
is there and you can also tell where
there's green screen but the overall
execution of this movie makes you forget
all that you're like it doesn't matter
and I like that this movie stuck to its
guns it would have been so easy to make
this movie a pg-13 action movie just for
the sake of getting more asses and seeds
know it's supposed to be rated R movie
it's not effective if it's not a rated R
movie so you need an action movie like
this that's the problem with most action
movies in general they try to recapture
that 80's 90's action movie type vibe
but now with the pg-13 rating because
it's all about the money Olympus has
fallen knew what it was it did its job
well it's really kind of reminded me of
Dredd in the mindset kind of way it's
like we know what the movie is but we
know you know what the movie is so we
all know what the movie is so let's film
the movie and make the movie to be what
we know the movie's supposed to be all
right now we're done enjoy I'm going to
say as far as an action movie is
concerned I would probably buy Olympus
has fallen on blu-ray
probably too high ever writing for this
movie but I can't just say no alcohol
required right so did you see Olympus is
falling what did you think of it what's
your favorite action movie that wasn't
made in the 80s or 90s now you know that
movie that tries to recapture it and
does it well whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you